we're just in this  infantile or adolescent stage with how  we're reckoning with social media  because it's so unprecedented the  instinct is to judge people at their  worst moment on their worst day and make  that a referendum on who they are as a  human being and we score points by  taking people down a peg on social media  i can't imagine everybody is going to  have their lives completely documented  everybody's saying stupid [ __ ] and  making mistakes and there's video of it  is everybody gonna get canceled how do  we  you know inject this social media  ecosystem with some level of humanity  and compassion and empathy we have to  make this  move toward  a different  way of looking at people's mistakes and  flaws and humanity